The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation, or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Ladies and gentlemen,
welcome to this
lecture on nonlinear finite
element analysis of solids and
structures.
In this lecture I would like to
discuss with you the total
Lagrangian formulation of the
two-noded truss element.
In the previous lecture, we
considered the updated
Lagrangian formulation
of the same element.
We started from the general
continuum mechanics equation,
and obtained the governing
finite element matrices.
I would like to do the same now
for the total Lagrangian
formulation.
And we will see that to find
element matrices are indeed
the same that we obtained in
the updated Lagrangian
formulation.
Here we have the governing
equation of the principle of
virtual work that we derived
in an earlier lecture.
This, of course, is a governing
equation that we
apply to obtain the governing
equation, finite element
equations, for two or three
dimensional analysis, and also
for the truss element.
It's a very general equation
that we discussed earlier in
great detail.
We use this equation now
for the truss element.
And the first point that we have
to look at is what stress
measure and corresponding
strain measure do we
need to deal with?
Now for the truss, it is
important to realize that the
only non-zero stress is this
stress here, t0 S11.
In other words, only the 11
component is non-zero.
Let us look at this
fact in detail.
There's first of all, what we
might call a mathematical
explanation.
Let us assume, of course, that
the cross-section here is
constant, the same way as we did
in the discussion of the
updated Lagrangian
formulation.
And here we have the element in
its original configuration,
and the element has undergone
large displacements and large
rotation to get into this
configuration at time t.
Notice the length is
almost constant.
We have an epsilon there.
That, of course, stands for the
strain that the truss has
undergone, but that epsilon
is assumed to
be very, very small.
We will later on also look at
a similar picture, but this
red truss element at time t
will have to be moved into
this configuration here,
starting, in other words,
starting on the left-hand side
here, we simply move this
truss element here straight back
so that this node lies on
top of that node.
In other words, if I just show
it to you like that, it will
have rotated like that.
Notice that as far as the
derivation of the stiffness
matrix of the truss element in
this configuration, and as far
as the element force vector
derivation are concerned, it
does not matter whether we look
at this particular truss
element in this configuration,
or whether we move it back to
make this point coincide
with that point.
Well if we drive using what we
have discussed earlier the
deformation gradient for this
particular element, we
recognize that this is the
general expression.
Notice that X, of course, is
equal to R times U, R being
the orthogonal matrix, and U
being the stretch matrix.
Notice that in this X matrix
now, this here really is the R
component, and the U matrix is
nothing else but the identity
matrix with an epsilon added
to the 11 component.
And the product of R times U
gives you then, of course,
this right-hand side.
Since the truss carries only
the Cauchy stress, tau11,
corresponding to the tensile
force in the truss, we can
directly write down the Cauchy
stress in the stationary
coordinate frame
as given here.
This, of course, is nothing
else but a Mohr's circle
transformation.
Notice that our truss element
moves through the stationary
coordinate frame.
I pointed out earlier very
strongly that we always deal
with stationary coordinate
frames.
So this is the expression of
tau, the stress in the truss,
but written now in the
stationary coordinate frame.
So we have sheer components
and normal components.
Of course, if theta's is equal
to 0, then we have only here a
1, and all of these are the
components drop to 0.
If we now use our general
formula, that once again we
discussed earlier, to evaluate
from Cauchy stresses, second
Piola-Kirchhoff stresses,
we directly
obtain this result here.
Since epsilon is small, we
set this equal to 1.
And we have, indeed, that's
the only non-zero stress
component in this stress tensor
is the S11 component.
Well there's also a physical
explanation.
And that physical explanation
goes as follows.
We have initially, say, this
situation here in the
configuration at time zero
where 0S refer to the
configuration at time 0 is equal
to tau0, and that is
equal to nothing else than the
initial force in the truss
divided by the area, 0
components, of course, here.
If we now think of first
extending that truss element
by a very small amount as shown
here, notice that blue
truss element here corresponds
to the extended truss element.
It lies really on top of the
black, but in separating it
slightly out so that you can see
the different coloration.
Then this blue truss element can
be sort of corresponding
to, and I'm showing it now up
here, equal to a time T star,
which is really a
conceptual time.
We are pulling out the truss
first, and this means of
course, corresponding to that T
star conceptual time, we can
write down this equation here.
Surely there are 0
components here.
Now, we start rotating the truss
about the left node, and
the result is shown
on this U graph.
Now we have the RAD
configuration, theta is here,
and the stress tensor
that we are talking
about has not changed.
Why has it not changed?
Well because of this statement
down here, the components of
the second Piola-Kirchhoff
stress tensor do not change
doing a rigid body motion,
in particular doing
a rigid body rotation.
We discussed this statement
earlier in an earlier lecture.
It's a very important property
of the second Piola-Kirchhoff
stress tensor.
And this means, of course, that
the 0s which we had here
in blue remains 0's
here in red.
Very important point.
Well having identified then that
S11 is the only non-zero
stress component that we really
need to deal with in
the general principle of virtual
work, we can directly
write down this relationship
here.
It's nothing else than the
application of the general
equation, which we looked at
earlier, reduced to the
special form of the truss
element taking only the S11
component into account.
See here, S11, of course,
corresponding strains--
eta11, and here we have only
the 11 components as well.
The next step is to look at what
are the individual terms
in that equation.
Recognize that S11 is nothing
else than tP over A. C1111 is
equal to E. The volume,
of course, is
given as shown here.
And of course, we also recognize
that the stress and
strain states are constant
along the truss.
Once again, because we're
dealing with two nodes only,
and we can only have a lean
interpolation of displacement
between these two nodes, meaning
that the strains must
be constant, and the
corresponding stresses must be
constant as well.
We substitute these things into,
these relationships up
here, into the equation that
I showed you earlier and we
directly obtain this equation.
Notice that in this equation
now, we want to, of course,
express the strain terms
e11, eta11 in terms of
displacements, nodal point
displacements.
And that is achieved as
usual via a strain
displacement matrix.
This is the relationship here
corresponding to the linear
strain increment, and that is
the relationship corresponding
to the variation on the
nonlinear strain increment.
Notice again, and I've pointed
it out a number of times
already earlier, that we write
this right-hand side in such
way that the right-hand
side is equal to
the left-hand side.
Therefore, these BNLs are
defined such that the
right-hand side is equal
to the left-hand side.
Also remember, u hat here, this
hat up there, the nodes,
the [? discrete ?]
nodal point displacements are
listed in this vector.
And here they are.
Notice upper superscript refers
to the nodal point.
Lower subscript refers to the
directions, the coordinate
directions that we
are looking at.
Similarly, of course, for node
two, 2 up there, and
1 and 2 down here.
We go back to our general
continuum mechanics relations
that we discussed earlier, and
identify that the total
increment in the
Green-Lagrangian strain is
given via this relationship
here.
Notice that this relationship
is obtained from the general
equation of this epsilon 0 IJ.
Of course, I and J are now
equal to 11 for the truss
because S11 is the only non-zero
stress that we just
have been considering earlier.
So we'll go into our earlier
view graphs, the information
that we discussed earlier.
To look up the equation on 0
epsilon IJ, we set I and J
equal to 1.
There is a k also in that
equation if you look back.
That k goes from 1 to 2 now
because we're looking at the
two dimensional motion
of the truss.
If you have a three dimensional
motion, then, of
course, we would have to let
k go from 1 to 2 to 3.
Here we have k only going from 1
to 2, that's why you see the
2 at the highest
subscript here.
And automatically, you would
get this equation.
Notice that the linear part in
here gives us the linear
strain increment.
And that the nonlinear part in
here gives us the nonlinear
strain increment.
And if we take the variation
on that part, we directly
obtain this relationship here.
We like to write this now in
matrix form, and that is
achieved as shown down here.
Notice this part, of course, is
nothing else than what we
have up here written
in matrix form.
There is, of course, in the
total Lagrangian formulation
the initial displacement
effect.
And that initial displacement
fact lies in
these derivatives here.
This one and that one.
And we need to evaluate them.
We can evaluate them from
kinematics, as shown in this
picture here.
Notice that we have moved
the truss now, as
I pointed out earlier.
We would do to the nodal point
to coincide such that, I
should say such that the
nodal points or nodal
point one has not moved.
Once again, that is quite OK.
If we want to derive the
stiffness matrix and force
vector of the element, because
those quantities are not
affected by this rigid
body translation.
Here we have theta, and notice
these are displacements that
we call delta tU2, delta tU1
with a negative sign there
because this displacement would
be measured positive in
the opposite direction.
And we can directly see that
this differentiation here is
nothing else than this
value right here.
From the kinematics.
Similar, this differentiation
is nothing else than sin
theta, once again, from
the kinematics.
So we have the initial
displacement effect in these
derivatives, and can evaluate
those as shown by these
functions here.
We also want to, of course,
evaluate these derivatives
here, 0U11, and in fact,
0U2 comma 1.
And we recognize that, as I
pointed out earlier, the
strains are constant.
Therefore, this is a constant
value, and in this
differentiation it's really
nothing else than this
relationship here.
We take the difference in the
nodal point displacement, and
divide by L. Quite the same
way as we did it for the
updated Lagrangian
formulation.
You can, therefore, write down
this differentiation, these
two derivatives here, as shown
on the right-hand side.
Now, we are ready to take
these expressions and
substitute into the right-hand
side of the
linear strain term.
Notice that this gives
us one term here, and
another term there.
Let's look at these terms.
This term here comes from
that part there.
And this term here, down here,
comes from that part there.
Let's look at this second
term a little closer.
This here is, of course, the
initial displacement effect.
All of that I should say
is really the initial
displacement effect.
But if these terms are 0 here,
then, of course, initial
displacement effects drop out.
So therefore, these two terms
here are the important ones,
and we can see that they are
written in this vector here.
We just derived them earlier.
Notice that this matrix, this
vector here, is given by this
matrix there multiplied
by the nodal point
displacement vector.
And of course, this total here
gives us the initial
displacement effect, which
is captured in t0BL1.
The sum of t0BL1 and t0BL0, of
course, gives us a linear
strain displacement matrix.
And that summation
is performed on
this view graph here.
Notice we have written these
terms once again.
Of course, if you had to
multiply out in order to get
t0BL1, the sum of these two
gives us this strain matrix,
the linear strain displacement
matrix.
And we now notice that in the
linear strain displacement
matrix, cosines and
sines of thetas of
the angle theta appear.
That is something
to keep in mind.
For the nonlinear strain
displacement matrix, we look
at our nonlinear variation on
the nonlinear strain term.
Here it is on the
left-hand side.
And we substitute for the
differentations the way we
have been doing it for the
updated Lagrangian formulation
of the truss.
And we recognize, of course,
that this part here is given
by what is underlined as blue.
And this part here is given
by, again what's
underlined in blue.
And then this part here is the
nonlinear strain displacement
matrix, the BNL.
That part right there.
Well if we now use all this
information, we directly
obtain the stiffness matrix and
stiffness matrices, and
force vector off the
truss element.
We substitute into here from
what we derived earlier, and
directly obtained
this expression.
And what's underlined here in
blue is, of course, the linear
strain stiffness matrix
of the truss element.
And notice that this linear
strain stiffness matrix is
identically equal to the linear
strain stiffness matrix
of the updated Lagrangian
formulation truss element.
We use this term to obtain
the nonlinear
strain stiffness matrix.
And we notice that this
nonlinear strain stiffness
matrix is identically equal to
what we derived earlier in the
updated Lagrangian formulation
as well.
The force vector, the F vector
for the truss element is given
on this view graph and
is obtained from this
relationship here.
Notice it's, once again,
identically equal to the force
vector of the updated Lagrangian
formulated truss
element as well.
And so we notice that to find
all the matrices that we
obtain in this total Lagrangian
formulation are the
same matrices that we already
had derived in the updated
Lagrangian formulation.
Important point to recognize
is that the coordinate
transformation used in the U.L.
formulation is contained
in the initial displacement
effect of the T.L. formation.
Let's look at that a
little bit closer.
What this means is that in
the updated Lagrangian
formulation, we did the
evaluation corresponding to
the configuration
at time t with a
local coordinate system.
And then after that derivation
was performed, we transformed
the nodal point variables to the
global coordinate system.
In the total Lagrangian
formulation, we obtain the
matrices directly corresponding
to the global
coordinate system through the
initial displacement effect.
Now, the same can also be shown,
of course, for other
elements, and we have looked
here, particularly at a
two-noded beam element.
And we have asked ourself the
question then which method or
which formulation is always
more effective?
If you use numerical
integration, as we might want
to use for the beam element,
particular we have to use if
we want to capture
elastoplasticity effects.
Then clearly, the updated
Lagrangian formulation must be
more effective because what
you are doing in the total
Lagrangian formulation is to
carry these cosines and sines
theta terms along for every
integration that you're
considering.
In the numerical integration,
the product of B transpose CB,
with the B containing the
initial displacement effect
now, is much more expensive
than the product for the
updated Lagrangian formulation
where the B does not contain
this initial displacement
effect.
So in the updated Lagrangian
formulation, the B matrix is
much simpler.
We do the numerical integration
with a simpler B
matrix along the beam element,
and the details are given in
this paper.
And once we have done the
numerical integration, we
simply transform the nodal point
displacements from the
local coordinate system.
The [? coord ?] system, we call
it a [? coord ?] system
when we discuss the updated
Lagrangian formulation of the
truss element, and we transform
these nodal point
displacements to the global
system only once by this t
transpose kt product.
So this means then that
certainly for a two-noded beam
element, the total Lagrangian
formulation is not as
effective as the updated
Lagrangian formulation, and it
is very natural to use the
updated Lagrangian formulation
because you get the same
result in the end.
For the two-noded truss, of
course, the numerical
operations involved are so
close, so close, that one can
really say the updated and total
Lagrangian formulations
are basically the same.
Let's now look at an example.
Here we have a truss, a simple
truss structure.
And we perform the analysis of
this truss structure using the
U.L. formulation, the T.L.,
total Lagrangian formulation
would give the same result,
as I just discussed.
And we want to particularly
calculate the collapse load of
this truss.
We also want to test the MNO,
the Materially Nonlinear Only
formulation.
The reason for testing this
formulation is to identify
what differences do occur, and
to understand more clearly the
U.L. Formulation, as well
as the MNO formulation.
Notice that for this truss,
the [? geo ?] matrix, the
geometric data are given here.
The material data are given
here in this table.
Notice that, of course, these
nodes dawn here are fixed.
Notice that we are putting a
load that pulls on the truss,
P, as shown.
And that we have two degrees of
freedom, U and V. So it's a
fairly simple problem, yet there
is quite a bit of meat
in it when one looks closely
at the solution.
And that's what we
like to do now.
We calculate first analytically,
the limit load,
the elastic limit load.
In other words, the load for
which the yield point is
reached in one of the members.
And in fact, for this particular
load, the side
trusses just become plastic,
and this is the
value of that load.
The ultimate limit load, when
the side trusses are plastic
and the center truss is plastic
as well, is reached at
this level.
If we use an automatic load
stepping incrementation, we
will discuss that in one of the
next lectures, we obtain
this response.
Notice P plotted vertically
here, and V, the displacement
corresponding to P, plotted
horizontally.
Notice that we come up here in
the step-by-step solution and
march along here.
There are two solutions
given, actually.
One with v1, very small,
and one with v1 larger.
This is here the parameters
that we use to start a
solution algorithm.
We have to start the solution
algorithm by imposing a small
value of displacement to a node,
and then the solution
algorithm can perform
automatically the total
step-by-step solution.
We will discuss that in one
of the next lectures.
And as you see, with the larger
value here, we get
these discrete points.
No difficulty solving
for this response.
Notice also that there's no
difficulty going beyond this
analytic elastic limit load,
shown here by the blue line.
If we were to look very closely
at this slope here, we
would see that it is
slightly positive.
You can hardly see it
from this graph.
This is the solution obtained
with the U.L. formulation,
with the U.L. formulation.
And once again, the T.L.
formulation would give
identically the same result.
We now consider an
MNO analysis.
MNO means Materially
Nonlinear Only.
No large displacement
effect included.
No geometric stiffening
Geometric stiffening, meaning
the effect of the nonlinear
strain stiffness matrix
being included.
So we want to use this
formulation, and once again,
apply the automatic load
stepping incrementation.
If the stiffness matrix in
that automatic load step
incrementation is not reformed,
in other words, we
keep the original stiffness
matrix, then almost identical
results are obtained to the
U.L. or T.L. formulation
solution results.
However, if the stiffness matrix
is reformed in the MNO
formulation, and for a load
level larger than the elastic
limit load--
remember, the elastic limit load
is quite a bit lower than
the ultimate limit load--
then the structure is found to
be unstable, as 0 pivot is
obtained in the stiffness
matrix.
I like to ask the question why
is that so to you now?
And ask you to just think
a little bit about it.
A few minutes.
And then when I come back, I
give you the explanation by
looking at the problem
once again.
I'd like to now address the
question that I asked you
before the break.
Namely, why, if we use the
MNO formulation do we get
virtually identically the same
results as in the U.L.
formulation if we only set up
a stiffness matrix that
corresponds to a configuration
below the elastic limit load.
If on the other hand, we setting
up a difference matrix
above the elastic limit load in
the MNO formulation, then
we cannot, so it's a problem.
Well the answer is that as soon
as the two trusses on the
side have become plastic, the
MNO formulation does not have
any more stiffness corresponding
to this degree
of freedom, meaning the matrix
is singular, and we cannot
solve the system of equations.
Whereas if we look at the U.L.
formulation, then we see that
the geometric stiffening effect,
or the KNL effect, the
nonlinear strain stiffness
effect, introduces the forces
that are acting in these two
elements into the structure
into the structure assemblage
as the stiffening part.
And of course, is a KNL matrix
corresponding to
this element as well.
So in other words, these three
KNL matrices corresponding to
these three elements, these
three truss elements,
introduce a stiffness into the
total structure assemblage,
meaning that we can still solve
the system of equations.
We also notice that these KNL
effect that we are carrying
along in the U.L. formulation,
when measured on the KL effect
are rather small.
And this means that the
response of the U.L.
formulation calculated with
the U.L. formulation is
basically the same as the
response calculated with the
MNO formulation.
As long, of course, we use
in the MNO formulation a
stiffness matrix that
corresponds to a configuration
below the elastic limit load.
Well this completes
this example.
Let us look at another
example.
And in this example, I like to
consider with you a pre-stress
cable, as shown up here, that
has initially a span of S. And
we then prescribe on the
right-hand side a displacement
to this node to bring this node
towards the left, meaning
that the cable will
sag through.
We want to calculate the
deformations of the cable, and
in particular, we want to have
the final deformations when S
is equal to 30 meters.
Notice that the cable
carries an initial
tension of 500 Newton.
And here we see the other data
corresponding to the cable.
This, of course, is a
geometrically nonlinear problem.
We want to use here the
U.L. formulation.
And the interesting part is that
to solve this problem we
have to use relatively small
time steps, or load steps,
because they're considering
it to be, of
course, a static solution.
We need to only allow small
perturbations in the nodal
point coordinates, because if
we do will allow too large
perturbations in the nodal point
coordinates, we find
that the out of balance loads at
the nodes become very large
and we have difficulties
solving the equation.
So we use many load steps with
equilibrium iterations so that
the configuration of the cable
is never far from an
equilibrium position.
In this particular problem, we
used full Newton iterations
without line searches.
We will talk about this scheme
in detail in the next lecture.
We use also convergence
criteria because we're
iterating, we have to break up
that iteration or stop the
iteration at some point.
And we will use these two
convergence criteria.
We consider these convergence
criteria in quite some detail
in the next lecture.
Notice that basically we are
saying is that the out of
balance loads shall be small
enough, and here we have an
energy criterion that
also has to be--
this measure has to be small
enough for convergence.
Once again, we will talk about
these in detail when we
consider the solution
of the equation.
Here we have a table that
summarizes the results.
In the first time step, puts the
gravity loading onto the
cable with a mass density that
was given, of course, on the
earlier view graph.
And we notice that with this
iterative scheme, we need to
14 iterations.
We then from time or load step
2 to 1,001 prescribed the
displacements in 1,000 equal
steps on the right-hand side
of the cable.
And we notice that we need
less than 5 or equal to 5
iterations per load step.
This might appear to
be a fairly large
number of load steps.
Of course, one could
now experiment
and bring this down.
If you try to bring this
down, this number, of
course, would go up.
And one could experiment
around.
But it shows what kind of
considerations are necessary
when you solve this problem,
namely that you don't want to
be too far away from the
equilibrium configuration
force of the cable in any one of
the load steps, and if you
are, then, of course, you will
need a large number of
iterations here, and your
iterative scheme might not
even converge.
Pictorally, the results are
shown on this view graph here.
Notice we have the undeformed
cable here.
And then with S equal to 55
meters, the cable takes on
this configuration with
S equal to 30 meters.
We see this configuration.
And if you were to try to bring
this point in further,
then to model the curvature
down here, of course,
properly, you would have to have
a finite discretization.
So this is probably the largest
amount that you want
to bring this point over
with this particular
discretization.
If you were to use a finite
element discretization, this
curve, of course, would
hardly change.
And this one here will change
a bit down here.
But these results are quite
acceptable up to S equal to 30
meters with this coarse
discretization.
And we have learned a bit
from this problem.
Thank you very much for
your attention.